uh three very intense but successful
rounds for you i would like to start
with this game between yourself and mama
the earth because the position out of
let's say the opening it looked so funny
it looked like a catalan but the bishop
was already on a2 there's a fiance queen
how did you feel about it yeah jan told
me this was his idea to play c4 and
yeah it was it looked like a bad
position maybe i shouldn't take but
i didn't want to
play passively
and
yeah what were you looking for in uh
this starting position what were your
main priorities well i thought i need to
castle i need to try to keep my c pawn
as long as i can
and if i can break with e5 or c5 at some
moment that would be good
but usually e5 and c5 were met by
d i mean e5 is usually met by d5
c5
rarely works but if it does then it can
be quite good um
yeah again this is this knight on d8
once d5 comes an iron d8 gets very
restricted so i thought i'll play knight
d7 knight b6 and castle short and try to
find a break later on
and when did you feel like you're oh
yeah i was very happy with c5 c5 at this
point because after b3 i thought it's
very messy and then i saw this move c5
it took it wasn't my first intention
first i thought either cb or bishop g4
followed by e5 some
cb bishop b3 uh i thought
okay of course black is totally fine but
uh
uh i thought white has compensation
because
knight e4 and knight c5 bishop a3 are
all kind of streaming in
um knight d4 next and yeah bishop d694
something like this so i thought that
white would have compensation here on c5
i really
was happy when i saw this move and
didn't see a clear follow-up for white
yeah and here i had to
you had an option of taking on d4 or
knight to c6 how did you make this
decision queen d4 knight d4 i i just
looked like such a mess to me i i wasn't
sure
i thought yeah of course this should be
good for black but uh too messy i didn't
want my queen to be in the center and
sorts of ideas so
i think it's like knight c6 yeah i see
c5 is the move i didn't even consider
this move
um
because
actually i don't know why because it's
very logical
and uh
yeah maybe we both didn't realize that
like knight d4 queen b7 usually this
pawn is uh
it's defended an entire game from the
night on d8 and then suddenly
um it's hanging so i
queen f3 then maybe you're thinking
about going queen e3 or queen yeah
i think that he underestimated the
danger after d5 um
but i yeah this knight before was very
important after that it's just
because bishop b2 bishop b5 that's his
problem that uh
he's he's not getting the diagonal line
and uh
bishop d4 is a threat yeah just take
take take
take i
uh okay i didn't realize queen e3 was
possible here so yeah i would have to
find this bishop d4 to
to really
um
press pressure clean off this diagonal
yeah queen b7 and take take take
and um the problem is beautiful a2 is so
terrible my knight on before is a
massive piece and the other problem is
94 queen e5 that his queen is dropped
which is um
bit of an issue
yeah
so
so yeah he
he underestimated i guess the danger
here and then
it was
i thought pretty simple for the rest of
the game like i didn't think he had very
very many chances to to survive the end
game some chances but not too many and
then let's go to your final game against
uh one gary kasparov it felt like the
position out of the opening was quite
balanced did you feel the same way yeah
i thought he was fine he found this nice
h6 g5 idea this was a
this was a i thought quite
uh quite an impressive
uh maneuver this uh g59 g7 and then move
the bishop and castle short
i guess i don't know there's a castle
shorter castle long
well he did castle short no but it's
like it's at this castle short but it's
it's a very long castle short so
yeah here here i realize i'm slightly
worse
um but i didn't think it was a big deal
uh bishop d3
i thought i more or less control and
then he played b6 very provocative
because he can just take and play for
example allow a5
no but it's provocative because it
allows bishop c4 like i played
um
then i thought that i
i started to take over
and then i completely lost control right
as i was taking over
like um
yeah b4
yeah rook ca was bad
take
take knight b3 and now knight of four
knight c5 queen f6 i thought i'm much
better
but i didn't see the way and uh so i
tried to play it safe
there's only one way with bishop to d7
and you're not even that much better you
know the thing is bishop d7 rook c5
bishop f5 i was considering this take
take queen c5
i mean like queen of five uh
queen c5 queen g i have queen c3 and
queen uh okay
g3 yeah yeah yeah i didn't see this okay
but i mean after bishop takes yeah yeah
he's also working
i don't think he's
not an easy position by any means no
even end games are quite difficult to
prove an advantage yeah and then he was
suddenly better again i thought
um
[Music]
like okay
yeah i played a very strange take in
rookie iii i mean it's very stupid
uh he could taken bishop g2 i don't know
what i was thinking
it was just terrible i mean
yeah quite quick i i didn't even realize
this pawn was hanging then suddenly i
see it's hanging and i'm like what am i
doing but he very quickly played rook c7
um
it was like a mutual blunder and then he
very quickly blundered here
yeah
and now this just wins a piece for you
yeah i still think it's like a very
difficult technical task if he defends
as well but
but it's probably quite difficult to
defend
fabiano uh levon came to the studio he
said this is probably the thing that he
enjoys most chess 960 no preparation uh
communication with his peers before the
round is it the same for you as well
yeah i do enjoy it i mean he's told me
before that he he would love to see more
uh chess 960.
like many times he's he's told me this
so
so i knew that uh that he really loves
this format
um i don't share quite the same love for
it but i do enjoy it i mean it's it's a
nice
um
[Music]
yeah a nice diversion from
you know regular chess where you have to
prepare a lot or not not so much to wrap
it in blitz but still
you know openings are a huge part of the
game and here
that doesn't play a part i mean opening
is huge but not opening preparation
doesn't really play a part at all i was
out of book
i moved to in every single
every single game today
fabiano congratulations we'll see you in
the next couple of days
and our congratulations as well javi as
he scores two and a half out of three